restar menos 2x cuadrada más 4 x 1 de 6
x cuadrada más 3 x menos nueve y como
siempre te encargo que pausa el vídeo y
veas si puedes lograrlo ok vamos a
trabajarlo juntos esto mismo lo podemos
escribir de la siguiente manera podemos
escribir 66 x cuadrada más 3
x menos 9 ya esto le voy a restar a esto
le voy a restar la otra expresión así
que la voy a poner en paréntesis voy a
poner por aquí mis paréntesis y voy a
poner aquí adentro menos 2 x cuadrada
menos 2 x cuadrada más 4 x menos 1 estás
de acuerdo ahora lo siguiente que voy a
hacer es distribuir este signo negativo
y hacerlo en cada uno de los términos
que tenemos aquí adentro por cada uno de
los monómeros así que vamos a hacerlo y
para eso voy a escribir a este
exactamente igual
se va a quedar igual y queda 6x cuadrada
más 3 x menos 9 y ahora voy a distribuir
este signo negativo y me va a quedar lo
siguiente el opuesto de menos 2 x
cuadrada o el negativo de menos 2 x
cuadrada bueno eso es lo mismo que 2x
positivo estás de acuerdo y entonces voy
a quedar
2x cuadrada y después me va a quedar el
negativo de 4 expositivo o podemos
pensarlo como el opuesto de 4x menos 4x
muy bien y para acabar me va a quedar el
opuesto de menos 1 o dicho de otra
manera el negativo de menos 1 y eso es 1
positivo muy bien lo único que hice fue
distribuir el signo y ahora qué te
parece si sumamos los términos que
tienen x cuadrada para eso primero me
voy a fijar en 6x cuadrada aquí tengo 6x
cuadrada ya está la puedo sumar a 2x
cuadrada y que me va a quedar bueno 6x
cuadrada más 2x cuadrada es lo mismo que
8x cuadrada estás de acuerdo nos
quedamos con la misma potencia y
solamente sumamos los coeficientes 6 más
2 es 8 8 x cuadrada
x cuadrado así que ahora vamos a
fijarnos en los términos x y aquí tengo
a 3x y por acá tengo menos 4x y a
sumarlos que me va a quedar es decir me
estoy fijando en los términos que tienen
grado 1
entonces si tengo 3x ya esto le quito 4
x o podemos fijarnos en los coeficientes
3 menos 4 es menos 1 por x así que lo
voy a poner como menos 1 x o recuerda
que esto mismo lo podemos escribir de la
siguiente manera simple y sencillamente
como menos x
recuerda que menos 1 x es lo mismo que
menos x y ahora podemos fijarnos en los
términos constantes en este caso tengo
menos 9 más uno menos nueve más uno
fueron eso es muy sencillo es menos x
- 8
y ya con esto acabamos lo hemos logrado
y una cosa que puedes ver bastante
interesante aquí es decir bueno ojo
empecé con un polinomio con este de aquí
ya él le reste este otro polinomio de
verde y date cuenta que nuestro
resultado fue otro polinomio y esto
siempre pasa si tú piensas no sé en el
conjunto de los polinomios déjame
ponerlo por aquí este de aquí va a ser
mi conjunto de los polinomios déjame
ponerlo
no mios muy bien si tu piensas en este
conjunto de todos los polinomios y tú te
tomas a este vamos a ponerle un nombre
este de aquí le voy a llamar px y estaba
por aquí este es pd x y era uno de los
polinomios que vivían en el conjunto de
los polinomios aquí tengo a px y después
nos tomamos a otro polinomio por aquí
este deber de que vamos a llamarle q de
x déjame ponerlo con este color y este
va a ser q de x entonces lo voy a poner
por acá también me tome acude x y
después con estos dos aplique una cierta
operación en este caso la operación fue
la resta así que déjenme ponerlo de esta
manera a éste le aplique a una cierta
operación que fue la resta y esta
operación nos dan como resultado otro
polinomio u otro polinomio que lo voy a
poner justo por aquí así que pongamos de
un nombre
esta respuesta final voy a decir que
este de aquí fue fx entonces obtuvimos a
efe de equis y cada vez que te pase esto
es decir que obtuvimos como resultado un
polinomio o dicho otra manera obtuvimos
un elemento del conjunto de los
polinomios digo tú lo puedes pensar como
un conjunto de cosas lo que a ti se te
ocurre puedes sentirte más cómodo
pensando en los números enteros o en
cualquier conjunto de números en este
caso estamos hablando del conjunto de
polinomios pero puedes pensarlo en
general nosotros comenzamos con dos
polinomios pd equis y q de equis que son
dos elementos del conjunto de polinomios
tú tomas dos elementos de conjunto y le
aplicas una cierta operación en este
caso la operación fue la resta y como
obtuvimos un elemento del conjunto
entonces decimos que el conjunto es
cerrado bajo esa operación entonces en
este caso podemos decir que el conjunto
de polinomios es cerrado bajo la resta
escribiendo aquí el conjunto con
punto
de polinomios x
y no míos
cerrado cerrado
bajo bajo la resta en este caso bajo la
resta y ojo no te lo he demostrado aquí
solo hicimos un ejemplo y bueno en este
ejemplo le restamos a un polinomio u
otro polinomio lo obtuvimos un polinomio
hay demostraciones más rigurosas sobre
esto pero así esto es lo que sucede es
decir tomamos un caso particular donde
teníamos dos polinomios y obtuvimos otro
polinomio después de aplicarle la
operación resta y si siempre pasa esto
entonces la forma elegante de decirlo es
que el conjunto de los polinomios es
cerrado bajo la resta y la noción de
cerradura es una noción muy elegante
dentro de las matemáticas pero realmente
no es complicada si tienes dos o más
elementos cualesquiera de un conjunto y
les aplica una operación y obtienes otro
elemento del mismo conjunto entonces
puedes decir qué
este conjunto es cerrado bajo esa
operación